In fourteen eighty, Ivan refused the tribute and faced the Horde across the Ugra river.
Both armies waited.
Then the Mongols turned and rode away.
Two and a half centuries ended without a battle.
It is remembered as the Great Stand on the Ugra, and it is one of the quietest endings to an empire on record.
Ivan then did something deliberate.
He demolished the old white stone Kremlin and brought Italian architects to rebuild it in red brick.
Those are the walls you still see today.
The Italians brought the brick, the engineering, and the swallowtail battlements you can still count along the top of the wall.
In fifteen forty seven his grandson was crowned with a title no Russian ruler had used before.
Not prince.
Tsar.
From the word Caesar.
This was not a change of rank.
It was a claim to inherit the authority of Rome itself.
Moscow now claimed to be the third Rome.
The first fell to barbarians, the second to the Ottomans, and this city declared itself the last one left standing.
The man who took that title was sixteen years old.
He began as a reformer.
He ended as something the Russian language gave a permanent name to.
His mother was poisoned when he was eight, and he grew up surrounded by the men he suspected of doing it.
Ivan the fourth.
Grozny.
Usually translated as terrible, though the word sits closer to formidable, or awe inspiring.
Both readings turned out to be accurate.
He built this.
Saint Basil's cathedral, raised to mark the conquest of Kazan, is the most recognisable building in Russia, and it came out of his reign.
Nine chapels on a single foundation, and no two of them alike.
He also built the oprichnina.
A private force answering to him alone, with authority to seize, torture and execute without explanation and without appeal.
They rode in black, on black horses, carrying a broom and a severed dog's head as their emblem.
For seven years the state made war on its own population.
Entire cities were purged.
Novgorod, a rival trading power, was broken so thoroughly it never recovered.
And while the Tsar was hunting enemies inside his own borders, the real enemy was quietly assembling outside them.
In fifteen seventy one the Crimean Tatars rode north, went around the army entirely, and set Moscow alight.
The city burned almost completely in a single day.
The death toll was enormous, and the estimates still vary widely.
The Kremlin walls held.
Almost nothing outside them did.
Ivan's dynasty died with his sons.
What followed is called the Time of Troubles.
Famine, pretenders, civil war, and finally a Polish garrison sitting inside the Kremlin itself.
By sixteen eleven Moscow was occupied, burned again, and leaderless.
This is the closest Russia has ever come to simply ceasing to exist as a state.
A Polish garrison held the fortress, a Swedish army held the north, and there was no agreed Tsar anywhere.
The recovery did not come from the throne.
It came from a merchant in Nizhny Novgorod, a butcher named Kuzma Minin, who raised the money and the men alongside a prince named Pozharsky.
They marched on Moscow with an army raised by public subscription, not by a crown.
In sixteen twelve they retook the Kremlin.
A new dynasty, the Romanovs, took the throne the following year, and held it for the next three hundred.
The day they entered the Kremlin is still a national holiday.
And then Moscow lost the one thing it had spent centuries acquiring.
In seventeen twelve, Peter the Great moved the capital to his new city on the Baltic.
Saint Petersburg was built facing Europe.
Moscow was left facing its own past.
For two hundred years Moscow was the old capital.
Respected, ceremonial, and no longer the place where decisions were made.
The city went quiet.
Which is what makes the next chapter so strange.
The most famous event in Moscow's entire history happened while Moscow was not the capital at all.
Eighteen twelve.
The largest army Europe had ever assembled crossed into Russia with a single objective.
Force one decisive battle, and dictate the peace.